hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 21 video completely
bananas all kinds of stuff to talk about
I'm so excited about season 2 after
seeing Grodd in this episode it's gonna
be so much fun as many compromises as TV
shows have to make because of budgets
and time constraints I think they did a
really good job and the CG technology is
only gonna get better as we get along in
seasons so if you like the way he looks
now it's gonna get easier and cheaper
for them to do him in future season so
we might see him more and more there's
just careful first bush in the episode
if you haven't seen it yet starting with
top five moments number five iris finds
out that Barry is the flash you may have
noticed the iris outrage running
throughout the episode this really
addresses everything that's been
building up with her character all
season long she's the last person to
find out and she blames a lot of the
problems they're having on the secrets
everyone's been keeping and she and
she's right she's not wrong that isn't
to say things wouldn't be bad it's just
that Eddie would not have been captured
as we've seen that's already had some
negative consequences it's like they're
trying to sow the seeds for Eddie
breaking with team flash like as if
they're gonna be at odds in future
seasons look at the byline on that
newspaper
iris marries Barry we better give this
ring back to Grandma so much awesome
Thawne family speechifying on to number
four the reverse-flash evil monologuing
just in general Tom Cavanaugh is
starting to look more and more like the
eobard thawne of the comic books he has
this really crazy white hair as you can
see Harrison wells hairdo is like slowly
been getting crazier and crazier as we
go along even the way he acts is
starting to get a little crazier and
crazier now go back and watch an episode
from really early this season he's very
calm very collected but in the last
couple of episodes he started to act
crazier and crazier it's just like the
writers in the actor Tom Cavanagh are
trying to take his you know show version
of eobard thawne as close to the comic
book version as possible by the end of
the season I was a genius where I came
from
think about how smart that makes me here
there was one episode where he actually
said he was giving a lecture somewhere
he got the name professor zoom when he
was lecturing at the flash Academy in
the future he became like a doctor of
speed force in flash science remember
this is the 25th century he dropped all
kinds of Easter eggs to about about the
other people in the flash family
the members of the Thawne family so just
right off the bat you have three really
big ones
there's cobalt blue who is actually
secretly Barry's twin so it's kind of
like an alternate timeline version of
the flash I know that's who everybody
wants Eddie to turn into this season the
theory that the reverse flash might turn
him into cobalt blue then there's Bart
Allen Kid Flash
also known as impulse he's half Thawne
from the future who comes back in time
and joins Teen Titans then you have
inertia
Thaddeus Thawne those are just the big
ones but in Barth odd just throws it in
Eddie's face that he is the only member
of the family that hasn't done anything
big so we have to consider how he's
going to process that is that going to
make Eddie do something crazy to try and
make a name for himself on to number
three the return of general Eiling
clancy brown such an amazing actor I'm
always happy when he comes back the
reveal is is that Grodd has been mind
controlling him this whole time ever
since he captured him during the last
time that we saw him and as the show
explained since the particle accelerator
explosion ever since then bharat has
like slowly and slowly been getting
smarter and smarter bigger and bigger so
just like the flash will probably see
his abilities evolved too although I
think they want to balance that
character out but they don't want him to
overpower the flash by too much they
want it to be something of an even fight
so as powerful as the flash gets in
season two just expect grodd's abilities
to get better - on to number two the
flash versus Grodd one of the biggest
weaknesses of the Justice League is
susceptibility to psychic attack and
magic they have amazing abilities but
it's just as easy for a super villain to
come along and put the Whammy on them as
you know as cisco calls it and turn them
into a weapon of evil
I like that Cisco and Caitlin remember
how much of a contribution Harrison
wells has been to their cause what's
probably gonna happen is the show is
probably gonna find a way to replace
Harrison wells in there they'll get
better at helping Barry solve problems
with technology and science but they'll
also probably weave Ray Palmer and and
other smart characters in somehow and
guest spots we don't really know if Tom
Cavanagh is gonna stay on the show in
season two so if he leaves what they'll
probably do is they'll just say you know
Cisco and Caitlin rising to the occasion
just getting better and better the whole
callback to the supersonic punch was so
great and given that we just got age of
Ultron and had that like the science
brofist that's all I could think about
the Hulk in the Hulkbuster punching each
other at the same time
supersonic science brofist in the comic
books brought also has super strength
although on the show he's an 800-pound
gorilla the flash doesn't look like he
weighs a whole lot so you know I don't
think they need to hype up super
strength quite as much but he's just
like slightly more impervious to attacks
to physical attacks that's why when he
got hit by that subway there there was
no way it was gonna take him down it was
just gonna be a minor inconvenience if
you're wondering why they included that
King Kong end tag you know with him
climbing the building and jumping off
it's just to let you know that he's
coming back in the future and to have a
little bit of fun when I think Grodd
jokes I think Donkey Kong first but you
could go Planet of the Apes
you could go King Kong any direction you
want Cisco was on fire with movie
references this week and finally my
number one WTF moment the reverse-flash
is going to reactivate the particle
accelerator to go home some of the
promos have revealed a few moments from
the finale it just shows the particle
accelerator activating that device that
the reverse-flash has the technology
might be something based on Farooq's
abilities something to siphon off the
Speed Force from the flash so he might
be using that to power the accelerator
in some grand device that will allow him
to time travel as in like you know the
flash will be running around inside the
particle accelerator it kind of looks
like a giant track anyway so just
imagine Barry just running in giant
circles more to the idea of time travel
- who else has noticed the back half of
the season how much more time they've
spent standing or sitting in that
treadmill room Barry did it twice in
this episode first when he was talking
to Iris early in the episode and then
again with like this big giant wide shot
of the treadmill at the end of the
episode the show is doing everything
short of beating us in the face with the
treadmill something is going to happen
with this treadmill there are too many
iconic images in the comics of the
reverse flash in the flash battling on
the treadmill for them to not do
anything with it in a big WTF way so
here's my big question for you guys do
you think that the reverse flash as part
of his ultimatum is planned to go home
is gonna make Barry run around at
SuperSpeed inside the particle
accelerator to charge the treadmill or
some other device so that the reverse
flash can siphon his power and run
himself home I just feel like particle
accelerator Plus Barry Plus treadmill
plus reverse flash equals time travel to
the 25th century
so I've already done a video about
grodd's history and the comics all had a
link for that in the description but if
there's any other bonus videos you guys
want is we're approaching the finale
just let me know I mean there'll be all
kinds of spin-off news coming soon and I
just got confirmed for my press pass for
Comic Con arrow in the flash gonna be
doing all kinds of stuff there so we'll
get a lot of news about where they going
in season 2 of the flash next week is
gonna be a lot of fun too it's gonna be
a rogue episode it's called rogue err it
sounds like they might go full-on
metahuman Prison Break remember Eiling
said this prison isn't going to be able
to hold them forever
i'li also talked about calling on the
flash for help especially you know now
that Grodd in the reverse-flash are
their common enemies I think that meant
two things one will see Clancy Brown in
season 2 whenever we have Grodd episodes
and team flash might get some help from
Eiling in the finale like some tech even
if I link himself isn't in the episode
it's just that defeating the
reverse-flash is gonna be a group effort
from a lot of different people including
maybe some of the villains like you
might see the flash team up with some of
the Rogues just remember Captain colds
gun is one of the best weapons against
speedsters that we know about right now
so I'm totally doing a new Q&A this week
and new episode of arrow tomorrow it's
gonna be crazy WTF wedding so why you
guys wait for those videos you can click
here for my Grodd history in the comic
books and you can click here to catch up
with arrow thanks so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow
you